jillian uh that dress is so pretty it
makes my stomach hurt
what yeah but that's also i i meant it
it looks beautiful that's also a line
from the 2011 hit comedy people like
what is he doing this is from
bridesmaids it's a line from bridesmaids
i'm impressed by the delivery and you
know we know a thing or two about bridal
parties here in vegas so why not bring
the hit film to the vegas stage rocky is
live at the orleans hotel to explain hi
rocky how's it going out there
hey jillian jc i just want to give a
round of applause to jc for the delivery
of that line that was really really good
it was the uh it was that dress is so
pretty it makes my stomach hurt line you
guys remember that
so let's just talk about bridesmaids the
movie musical parody the unauthorized
because this one's getting a little uh
raunchier than the original so let's go
through who you guys are playing and
remind us for those who haven't seen the
movie in so long sure hi i'm nicole
unger i play annie walker in the the
musical parody yeah hi my name is luke
striffler i play becca as well as rhodes
multiple people playing multiple
characters hi i'm miley on saga and i
play lillian
hi i'm mckenna silva and i'm the female
swing currently portraying megan i love
these costumes are everything what went
into actually preparing these costumes
who was the costume designer ah actually
good question
yeah so we just worked as a team trying
to decide what vision we wanted to
portray in the show uh and got the
costumes in and ready oh i love it i'm
loving the wig oh thank you really it's
so good on you now okay so how much of
the actual movie is in this parody play
like you know how how close is it to the
actual movie i'd say it's pretty close
we obviously throw in a lot of parody
just because we need to so there are a
lot of things that you're going to be
like oh i like the way that they did
that it's going to be drastically making
fun of like drastically making fun of
the movie drastically
lovingly but drastically give us an
example
uh well so we do have some characters
that are like annie's roommates but not
necessarily the same so you have to come
see the show to see what that means okay
the world premiere is on wednesday and
it's going to be showing every friday
and saturday so coming up we're going to
go to fight club right guys
i'll send it back to you guys
thank you rocky we'll check back in with
you later on in the show such a great
movie i love that movie so i'm excited
for that show all right moving on to